ciao ragazzi ciao mai preciso il testo
risse siamo nuovamente ti sopporta chi
oggi ha rubato il nostro libro storie
coro della scuola dei misteri dobbiamo
completare tutta la challenge che gli
uomini nella vita reale non parlo da
dove dovremo iniziare e fa finta di
derisione lasciate un bel mi piace
scelto questo video perché se foto video
raggiunge i 20 mila mi piace ci sarà un
altro video di adium oggi nella vita
reale hanno più il mio libro storie polo
tempora di misteri
anonimo online e in tutte le librerie è
disponibile non potete non averlo
prendete le poi scriveteci nei commenti
qual è la vostra creatura preferita
dentro al libro perché dentro al libro
si sono le schede creatura con
tantissimi nazioni vi piacerà tantissimo
e ora st rispoli iniziamo subito la
challenge presto
è chiuso dobbiamo trovare la
combinazione di colore per aprirlo come
nel videogioco colore giusto è pieno di
colori potrebbero essere tutti i colori
guardiamoci bene intorno sono tantissimi
colori o non vado sorti a proposito
grazie dado porti per averci ospitato di
nuovi benissimo qua c'è qualcosa qui
anche qui in una pallina verde e io ho
trovato una pallina gialla cerchiamoli
anzi poeta forse ne una rossa 123 ce ne
manca solo uno meglio può niente qui
sembrava una mela
dirette rosa giallo rosso verde rosa
giallo
[Musica]
ma tube il libro 8 il mio libro da afa
specie più mio produrre idea di una
palette
che innanzitutto dobbiamo trovare il
gran pack 0 prima di avvicinarsi ad adua
chi almeno avremmo qualcosa per
difendersi l'urto ci guardiamo poi
intorno dove potrebbe esserlo
oggi vediamo la guarda c'è una maratona
un ritmo di
bruno allora dobbiamo solo trovare
l'accordo
io guardo fatto va bene
ma che
sto facendo la giocata
guarda che
ho trovato aggrappato l'angelo che bello
pronti a difendersi da di quattro sono
d'accordo bacchetta ecco fatto siete
caldi stiamo arrivando a prenderci il
libro il nostro libero
adesso chi spara ha subito batte 5 1
fra capito
timore non ti muovere o ti batti il
cinque con queste non si sta movendo non
vedi che immobile anzi non ti ricordi
quello che dobbiamo fare dobbiamo
attivare l'elettricità è solo così che
si muoverà e poi potremo trovare il
libro storie paurose dacci le chiavi
della stazza dell'attività hai capito e
tanto kiwan gino ci fai paura che
è che mi ha accarezzato
credo che sia meglio non provocarlo che
è
attrezzata che
l'immobile
adesso dobbiamo trovare la forza delle
lepri sito lui e con lui possiamo
attivare le lettere citavano lui andrà
via e potremo riprendere il nostro libro
chiuso
guarda c'è un lucchetto
non c'e dobbiamo dare una chiave
qualcosa proviamo ad aprirla siamo
dimmi una combinazione
potrebbe essere la mia serata lingua di
chi guarda il bicchiere il 12 3 vado a
cercare una soluzione forse nell'altra
sala perché non puoi lasciarmi solo con
queste cose tecnologiche io poi dopo non
ci capisco più niente penso ad esempio
quelli potrebbe essere numero di hacking
però vorrei per poter aprire il
lucchetto potrebbe essere uno due tre
grazie
non pensavo fosse così siamo marchio
della vita aspetto tanto da
aver tenuto
java fatto sono troppo guardava parte
lucchetto
quale numero il numero era vedere il
numero aspettando 23 era facile no il
numero di adeguati voluto esterno come
mai quasi un altro numero è beppe perché
versante imposizione era spostato all
importante che la porterebbe
[Musica]
cosa dobbiamo fare fatto vedere chi per
attivare l'elettricità
forse c'è un altro enigma da risolvere
qua per attivare l'elettricità a tremiti
ma e poi potrebbe essere non lo so
vediamo posto verde giallo verde blu
star è difficilissimo carteni abbiamo
bisogno abbiamo bisogno del filo di voce
c'è un paio in più ci sono troppi
elementi qua però sicuramente rimarremo
paolo tocco di carboni mi piace spronare
il cervello facente allagati mare a
questo è
attivato l'elettricità sì ho risolto
l'enigma bastava semplicemente
accenderemo l'invito l'interruttore ed
ecologisti città
[Applauso]
guarda presso dove dobbiamo dare tutti
qualcosa pochi luoghi è sparito quindi
sicuramente sarà dentro la fabbrica di
giocattoli
però dobbiamo assolutamente entrare il
prima possibile per recuperare il nostro
link occhi attenti ai rumori e perché
non lo so potrebbe essere che si
nascondeva dietro al libro
che
sono partite le more lenkrad pac ma non
puoi fare così ogni volta a prenderci
non ho avuto paura
si
sa lo devo prendere
altrimenti con che cosa si difendiamo
c'è ragione un'ottima idea vado subito a
ricaricare il club sa che non ti
preoccupare io tricarico incappato
enrico viii sì sì avevo remo aspetta
come si fa questo adesso che facciamo
come scaricando difenderti non
vieni quell'ombra no non vedo niente c'è
qualcosa che si è mosso proprio laggiù
in fondo forse o di luoghi e laggiù che
ci aspetta sa bene quindi siamo sicuro
quindi non siamo proprio al sicuro qua
dentro però dobbiamo sbrigarci per
recuperare il nostro libro sarebbe
accorto prima io ho fatto
sono caduto maestà ma perfetto srotolato
ma qua c'è lo sciopero non si può salire
da qua bisogna fare il giro salire dalla
stop rai dove fare il giro siamo qui
basta salito dallo scivolo dice la
parola stessa scivolo cioè no aspetta
quel salire no questo è shanxi va beh
insomma si chiude poi si fa prima da te
fai come vuoi ci vediamo dopo la sua
operazione ok va bene ciao c'è problema
io salgo da qui mica faccio tutto il
giro queste sale di qualche ci vuole
tanto lo dice la parola stessa scivolo
cioè nel senso non è che va così
difficile no uno si mette qui cammina un
po e piano piano sale no piano piano
sale piano piano tale anche se volendo
effettivamente si scivola e si è una
scivolata male che si scivola l'italia
in genio
perché non ti ascolto mai orami
differenti la tesi c'è ragione ma io ci
provo per l'ultima volta che vedo io
no non ha funzionato dai sbrigati talita
guarda te l'ho detto che ce l'avrei
fatta non mi sembra proprio che ce l'hai
fatta
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
sempre il solito
faccio in giro per non ci passa più
fallita
meriterebbe eravamo qui dove ho detto
che stai mangiando troppo però non ci
portino avanti ho chiesto aspetta tira
tira condotta giovani
a detta
dell
proviamo andare di qua in questi tubi
forse quando usciremo a trovare il libro
avete sentito
lasciate un mi piace per portarci
fortuna sì forse c'è qualcosa in uno di
questi tubi
di
scappamento
di quella casetta li
aspetta non essere preso due ci guardi
via libera non c'è nessuno cuore almeno
credo a meno che non sia nascosto da
qualche parte qui
sono rotolato ok forse è meglio se
andiamo nell'altra area prima che arrivi
a chi va chi ok sarà più a chi però non
lo so forse ci sta già cercando forse
dobbiamo superare quegli ostacoli li
guardo tutti questi popoli attivati lui
prima era pronto posto prima io o
privato vado prima io vado prima io tu
stai attento a non inciampare però è
perché se lo stai attenta potrebbe
essere molto pericoloso ha capito
ma mi ero raggiante taroni già bari non
avevo visto che c'era quel coso lì e
sono inciampato
o impossibile ci casco questo
ninja insomma una legge rotolante
insomma non c'è un modo di disattivarli
e
questi sono quelli di luoghi e questi
mesi
brava ci hai fatto un prestito devo
andare allora io penso che cosa vedono
simbolo è l'unica strada o no porterà
c'è un altro simbolo troppo quando non
abbiamo trovato pro quindi dobbiamo
tornare giù per aria
vieni vieni rai.tv di muffa non voglio
scendere dallo scivolo luce un'altra
metri ei metodi quello
di tale grazia
e va bene voi la guerra è guerra
teoria
tutti
[Musica]
benché di questo
ecco credo io ho detto di no
però lo facciamo lo possiamo dare
prova
questo ci sta provando
eventi come le spalle
a chi
non ha un piano di no
voglio dire arrivo sali su luoghi non lo
vedo più dove sarei andato si è
presentato l'importante che non sia
arrivando qua no no ce la possiamo fare
adesso non è che moreni qua ma no era lì
un attimo fa scopa con dei capi non c'è
più e non hanno visto che non c'era
portati bene intorno anche voi
controllate via di un luoghi non sia
fatta dai sbrigati che mi ha telefonato
dobbiamo trovare il libro si si si note
vedi il libro da qualche parte no non lo
vedo andiamo di qua
sono sicuro questa
verde verde cia gli occhi giganti aiuto
che ha paura che paura
ah no è un peluche
era solo peluche come un vero e non lo
so perché mi sono spaventato perché
pensavo fosse qualche amico di angri
wang e che magari ci vuole ci vuole
impedire di prendere il libro mi hai
fatto spaventare te lo dico io cosa
serve quel plus ma mi sono stati
ma questo e ferruccio che serve per
attivare la fabbrica dei giocattoli di
antigua di
ora dobbiamo solo trovare il rullo
trasportatore dei giocattoli per
attivare la fabbrica e mettere questo
peluche così accederemo la prossima area
forse riusciamo finalmente a recuperare
il mio libro attori e paurose ora
andiamo dobbiamo andare di qua
sicuramente se abbiamo trovato il
peluche per la giusta un altro scivolo
forse qualcuno della fabbrica ma per
accedere lì non dobbiamo salire su
dobbiamo tornare giù credo questo
vediamo si ri primo
prima che arrivi a tv e chi no la vita
ti stai sbagliando contadina che dirà
che si scende per arrivare qua si può
passare anche da sotto facciamo una gara
sì io passo da sotto tu fossi tasto per
chi arriva prima vita è
[Applauso]
inaccettabile
quel passaggio per accedere allo scivolo
vediamo vediamo si è fatto prima e
vitale no
ma quindi sei arrivata prima di me è
parecchio prima stavo già schiacciando
un pisolino figura e allora beta di
questo no ma insomma non si scherza non
devi far scivolare il giocattolo dallo
scivolo in questo modo potremo attivare
la fabbrica
io non ho sentito nessun rumore
aspetta aspetta bilancio io così faccio
un buco enorme
non so se siamo riusciti ad attivare la
fabbrica dovremo salire al piano di
sopra per capire se sta funzionando la
fabbrica
[Musica]
ok dobbiamo trovare il libro il prima
possibile ho sentito dei botti ho paura
che nei laghi si stia avvicinando questa
sala e grandissimo dove potrebbe essere
guardiamo si fanno intorno ma è proprio
sembrato di sentire dei passi in alto
magari proprio qui nel tubo aspetta un
attimo ma
guarda te l'ho mai nascosto
se fosse solo una trappola per attirarci
là sopra e poi ci prende guarda lavoro
dieci uomini
o no volevano una trappola dobbiamo per
forza a salire la sopra recuperare il
libro lo so che sicuramente ci sarà di
luoghi ma magari riusciremo comunque non
essere presi presto anche noi teniamo
gli occhi aperti anche voi state molto
attenti si chiama ci dobbiamo prendere
il libro riesco a vederlo che la quale
proprio in questo tubo che sei proprio
lì e occhi vuoti dove sarà
non si vede ancora non si vede qua
speriamo che non spunti fuori
all'improvvisa vero e proprio qualche
dubbio votare noi su questo tubo non mi
sembra di vedere niente dentro al tubo
quindi a chirurghi non è dentro al tubo
e da qualche altra parte si scopriranno
montaperto modernità che c'è ascolta ha
capito qualcosa
ho sentito dei passi prodotto sopra
quindi forse mese è stato però una
sbirciatina per vedere se c'è anche il
controllo e poi fammi sapere
sembra tutto ok a piedi dal e allora
andiamo dai ricatti d'amore moltiplicati
non abbiamo detto
addio a vis ha preso abbiamo rifatto
tutto il percorso ora risaliamo la folla
parliamo dovrebbe esser qua alla fine di
questo tubo al libro
sentito i rumori per caso no non son
rumore quindi non penso che sia un
barchino affetto e di qualcosa da lì
no non c'è niente devo solo percorrere
tutto il tubo è prendere il libro io mi
devo prendere in giro io sono dietro di
te
infatti monici ha preso di nuovo o siamo
risaliti qua all'ultimo piano orari
proviamo a prendere il libro dal tubo
sperando che a chi oggi non si sa ancora
quale non sento nessun rumore vorremmo
che questa è l'ultima volta sarà
ancora
bruni
ha preso luca ok vai a prenderlo su
questa volta
ho provato io ok
via libera ok andiamo mai non dovevo
dare
che ci sono video con tornare per prendi
abbiamo ripreso bravo finalmente
scappare da questa fabbrica dei
giocattoli di che cos'è questo rumore
intel e seviziate un 36 a corte
scappiamo rimane immobile
stai dicendo di no ha detto no non l'uno
partiamo direttamente dall'albero
partiamo dal blu e anche col 2 allora
facciamo che al 3 prendiamo e scappiamo
è il profilo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
[Risate]
dopo l'uomo stati prestiti non mi
concede professor siamo in un'altra area
della fabbrica se andate via gianelli lo
chiamo il ii premio
doveva essere qui in questo blog visto
che nell'altra stalla era ad entrare non
lo vedo però vale la pena cercare
andiamo e tv presso andiamo
[Musica]
ma mia madre ha raggiunto gioioso aiuto
un po dietro ma devo chi è qua
mi è scappato aiuto
aiuto st riposo sotto
sorrisino sono titoli
di qualità
massimo
bene di questo che voglio
no no
no
non velocità fosse mi sono molto piede
scappa scappa
questo ci servirà così eviteremo testa
brividi
prima che si blocchi oggi luoghi presto
un piano proviamo a far cadere kimwaki
da qua si è forse riusciremo a vincere
la zona quindi speriamo di riuscirci io
non sarò tirarlo può si sa solo che lo
finiamo e
mettiamoci questa prassi in piedi e
chiamiamolo aghi non ci pare niente
schiappa
un perdente segnali che goffo degli
interventi
si sta
arrivando
[Musica]
speriamo che il nostro biglietto è
arrabbiatissimo
aspetto stato
ottimo in fase di questo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
dobbiamo ancora trovare il libro
dobbiamo trovare fiore in fiore papavero
il bubi preghiamo sentiamo turn over se
non abbiamo ancora controllato in
guazzetto tu contro la pro non avendo
della piscina delle palline io
non credo che ci sia niente
quando qualcosa dai tu no infatto
progetto o
no non c'è niente dobbiamo cercare il
piano guarda bene tutte le immagini
l'aspetta il gruppo il bruco alle volte
mancano anche i fiori o sbaglio sì forse
siamo felici si dove potrebbe essere
guarda
di papavero un po pi quindi il libro
mobile che sta dentro
sì
l'abbiamo trovato
ora disponibile
correte subito a prenderlo non riuscire
a trasmettere diventano perché li terrei
con le immagini non ho nemmeno e ci sono
anche delle creature fantastiche le
scoprirete tutti all'interno del libro
correte a vederlo lasciate un bel mi
piace spiega questo video e ora villa
savo quanto casalinga su cui cliccare
per vedere inoltre altri video cliccate
su quella che preferite